it's kind of loosely based on your past
so it's a good good pass to have had
without making the movie i'm not sure
but uh but yes uh no at the time i asked
my dad if it was a good pass to have uh
that might not be the same answer is he
here tonight yes he is i think he's
gonna say he was not gonna come and then
i was saying i was like look you guys
don't have to come it's fine and then
they finally like
fine i'll come ten years ago channing's
dad and all of us were introduced to
magic mike the shirtless scenes sexy
dance moves and iconic crew including
matt bomer joe mingenello and matthew
mcconaughey he's kind of perfect he
knows how to talk and he knows how to
say things and he'd be talking about you
know the weather but somehow it's saying
it seems more
rich
just because it's coming out i'm kind of
his mouth
behind the scenes tell us a funny moment
between all the guys something that
happened because you cannot
not have laughed this entire set well we
did laugh six guys we all knew what we
had to end up doing you didn't show up
to this job and go well i don't think i
want to wear a thong you should do this
job you were like no we're all wearing a
thong now guess what we got to spend a
week working out what thong we want to
work on and that's supposed to be really
serious business the hardest part about
shooting this movie was not laughing
hysterically in the middle of takes so
yeah as soon as they yell cut we were
just screaming rolling on the floor
three years later dallas guys reunited
for magic mike xxl and e.t was on set
with them in georgia just a bunch of
friends got together to get some dough
started together i mean that's that's
what it is
and we have a lot of crazy times the
franchise continues with live shows in
vegas and london which we visited with
channing back in 2018. did you
envision like
this
uh no it's a joke in the movie that's
how much we didn't think that any of
this was gonna happen i mean we gave we
gave it to dallas to be like waiting for
our time to make our move take our show
globe and the third movie is going
global two magic mike's last dance just
wrapped filming across the pond earlier
this month well you know we expect you
to bring the heat so scale of one to ten
what are we getting we're getting 100 on
this one like we're getting 100 points
on this one i know we're gonna throw
everything in the kitchen sink at it
selma hayek joined the cast replacing
tandy wayne newton who stepped away for
family matters how much fun did you have
with salma selma came in and like
just was a like a tour de force like uh
she made everyone work harder on set
there is not a question in my mind of
why she is who she is and she's done
what she's done and she's going to keep
like i think just just blowing people's
minds i will do any movie with her
forever we all seemed like you had so
much fun well i don't know if i would
say it was hard it was hard i'm gonna be
honest like the movie the
movie with the movie was hard
[Music]
you